welcome to ramsay in 10 where each week
i'm going to show you all how to make
incredible dishes in just 10 minutes i
promise but if you get them done in 10
12 or 15 or 20 or even 30 minutes i
promise you it doesn't matter this
series will teach you the skills to make
you cook more confidently at home to all
of you this is ramsey and ten good luck
[Music]
right come on let's be honest everybody
is turning green but have you done it
with pasta full of vegetables cooked in
10 minutes i bet you haven't but after
this you definitely will so this dish is
delicious full of flavor and trust me
any member of your family is gonna love
this dish right uh oscar pandan let me
show the ingredients so obviously
fusilli now if you haven't got fusion
you can go with penne or even spaghetti
beautiful fresh kale
lime lemon garlic arugula
almonds
parmesan
and this little whizzer it's a beautiful
nutribullet that's going to blend that
beautiful green sauce then we're going
to finish that and run it through the
pasta and then top that with some
almonds right let's get 10 minutes on
the clock first off season that past the
water okay get the gas on there
and
be germs the olive oil okay this olive
oil sort of helps emulsify the sauce
now garlic
okay i said earlier
you can use a little chilli okay
don't sweat
about chopping the garlic super fine the
finer the garlic the quicker it burns
okay
so just
lightly
slice that garlic
and you know what
from there
in
get that gas up
and then again
literally start frying
that garlic off there
now
lightly seasoning okay i'm gonna put a
little touch of heat in mine just a
touch of chili flakes in there okay
once you start getting a bit of color on
that garlic okay
i'm gonna add my kale
now the kale's gonna be sort of lightly
sauteed and then we're gonna steam it at
the end i'll show you why
get that in there and literally cover
the base of the pan
with that kale now from there
you'll see this almost sort of wilt down
but not as fast as spinach and kale's
got that nice sort of rugged texture
running through so it's got some sort of
it's got some energy to it spinach
disappears kale cooked beautifully a
little touch of salt on top
salt on bottom a little touch
of pepper olive oil drizzled on top
okay
i'm gonna throw in a couple of the
almonds just now to get a little bit
toasty and make that sort of come
together as a flavor
pasta
turn up the heat i like to cook the
pasta quick this is fusilli fresh pasta
is going to cook literally in about
three minutes okay get a nice gentle
rolling boil
and roll that pasta in there bring up
the temperature super quick put the lid
back on i always like just to turn the
pan that stops any pasta underneath
literally
sticking to the pot oscar pan down
please i just want to look at this in
here
the kale is starting to wilt down okay
from there
get yourself a ladle
and then take some of the pasta water
which is full of starch and just go
round in there
that's the noise you want to hear time
please
[Music]
two and a half minutes down
nobody goes down right
from there sweat that off
turn the gas
get that heat back in there
and then look
you see that kale starting to break down
now i want to get a little bit of sort
of zest going on a little bit excitement
to that green kale
so look
in
with
my zest
and that starts to sort of
make the kale a little bit more vibrant
now look what's happening okay
the kale's starting to sweat and break
down past the water's giving it that
really nice touch of starch a little bit
of texture on top of that
color of anchovies again optional but
you need two
or three nice salted anchovies
chop them up
okay and literally
just lift that up
and throw them on top of the cow
now give that a really nice stir
as that kale starts to cook okay
smell
with that citrus at the end just sort of
lifts this
i don't want to overcook the cow okay i
want some structure in there
from there
get your
beautiful mix
collect all your kale sort of
one side
and fill up
that beautiful little blender
now you can use a blender
or
you can actually use a stick
mix as well this thing just does it
beautifully and quick
now from there
look get that juice
and literally just pour that
inside
can't throw that away the flavor in
there
it's crazy now
look
time please four minutes
coming up to halfway
give that pasta a little shake
now before i whiz that look a little
touch of olive oil okay a little touch
of seasoning
and then lid on
now i'm going to break this down gently
okay i don't want to go too puree so
it's just literally on
five seconds
got this beautiful
amazing sauce
now
look at that
put that back into the pan now
we start focusing
on the seasoning
spread that out
and look what's happened
it's broken down
and like i said you can put that in a
blender
or even a stick mix but now we start to
correct
the actual flavor
halfway
touch more olive oil
in
i'm gonna check my pasta
and look
bring that sauce down to sort of almost
a sort of almost like a nice creamy
richy density sort of texture
that pasta's beautiful
out
don't over drain the pasta
starch inside that fusilli
really helps thicken
the sauce
and now you bring the whole thing to
boil okay and this is where it starts to
sort of almost
come alive
beautiful
come there i'm going to start
mixing that in
and now you can see that nice
fresh vibrant green
flavor it's a perfect dish for us at
weekends especially after a run
or an hour in the gym a couple of hours
on the bike this is something that is
hearty
incredibly healthy but more importantly
so good
now
we use the kale we've cooked the kale
down sometimes i like to finish it with
a bit of rocket as well
inside the pasta
i'll show you that now that gives that
nice little peppery flavor
it goes all out
now
give that a little mix
and now you can see this whole dish
coming together beautifully
now from there
turn the gas down
and again
i'm gonna finish that literally
with some fresh lemon okay
i'm gonna add half of my
rocket in
fold that in
literally
and then with the other half i'm gonna
dress
that
turn that in
that's beautiful
seven minutes in three minutes to go now
that is beautiful
off with a gas okay
give that a little shake the remainder
of my fresh rocket a touch of salt
olive oil
a touch of lemon juice
i'm just going to glaze that
lightly
and just sort of dot that around
so i've got half rocket cooked
and then that nice sort of texture of my
almonds crunched through the hands
in
and then finally
a nice
salty beautiful aged parmesan
and go over the top
and there you have literally a beautiful
fresh vibrant
green healthy pasta dish
done
in under 10.
boom time please
you have one minute and 51 seconds
remaining [ __ ] i may be getting old but
let's be honest i'm getting faster bon
appetit
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsay intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey intent cookbook
inspired by this series and trust me
you're going to come out a much better
chef and if you like this video don't
forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck